depuis le début de la guerre
en Ukraine. Justin Trudeau
arrive avec un message
pour ses alliés.
(applaudissements)
- Au Par
un appel à la solidarité.
La meilleure arme des pays
occidentaux contre l'agresseur
russe est l'unité,remier minrem.
Ce sont les fondements de
la démocratie qui sont en jeu.
JUSTIN TRUDEAU,
premier ministre du Canada
soutenir les démocraties
partout partout partout à trave,
incluant les plus fragiles, et
lutter contre l'autoritarismfaie
plus pour l'Ukraine, dit-il,bone
et l'envoi d'armes.
- Nous devons appuyer les ge prt
Zelensky et les Ukrainiens
qui luttent pour leurs droits.
- Et il conclut en citant
son homologue ukraère...", dit-.
- Light will win over darkness.
- "... l'emportera
sur la noirceur."
Mais au-delà des grands
discoursrtout
l'occasion pour Justin Trudeau
d'encha
avec des leaders européens.
- On va aussi parler
des sanctions sans précédent
imposées sur PoutiON DER LEYON e
de la Commission européenne
- C'est aussi l'occasion
de réaffirmer la force
de notreoffensive politique
où le Canada tente de prouver
sa pertinence.
MÉLANIE JOLY, ministre
des Affaires étrangères
cette crise, c'est certainement
d'être ce pays qui aide à faire
le pont entre l'Europe et
les États-Unis et certainement
aussi les Britanni
viendra autour de la table
de l'OTAN jeudi, un sommetn somt
extraordinaire des leaders
de l'Alliance, en compagnie
du présilles
sanctions...
de l'OTAN en Europe de l'Est,
et l'occasion surtout de lancer
un sérieux avertissement
à Vladimir Poutine.
"L'utilisation d'armes
chimiques en Ukraine, prévient
le secrétaire géit complètement
la nature du conflit."
Lors de ce sommet
extraordinaire, lelliés de l'OTN
devront surtout prouver
que leurs paroles vont aussi
se traduire en actions
encore pfreiner freiner freiner.
La pression est grande entre
les attentes du peuple ukrainien
et le risque pour l'Occident
directe avec la Russie.
Ici Louis Blouin,
Radio-Canada, Bru